the story goes that ivan reitman the
great director was with robin williams
and the two of them approached you and
said you should do a comedy and since
you were a fan of ghostbusters you're
like yeah okay write me a comedy and
then they come to you with this absurd
idea that you and Danny DeVito are twins
which is ridiculous on paper that sounds
like the biggest box-office bomb on the
planet
what made you trust those guys because
at this point you got to make really
smart decisions
it was after we've spent the evening
together where Ivan Reitman and Robin
Williams said to mrs. you are so funny I
know I said I do have a funny side to me
and in the comedic side and it said you
should see this on the screen our Lord
we should see this on the screen and I
said well I say Hollywood refuses to do
a comedy with me because they make all
the money in the world with the action
right so they're not about to switch now
I mean the saying don't fix but it's not
broken
yeah right and so of course they
continue doing the action movie so Ivan
said it says well I would do something
with you and I said look I need your
help
yeah I need all of your help because I
just cannot do it by myself I said they
won't accept the idea of a comedy and so
Ivan put this project together right and
with Danny DeVito
which Danny DeVito your first choice
there was no choice yet it was only a
bit of discussion one time the studio
and Ivan and then I said you know the
way it's written is that he's told the
opposite why don't we get someone that
is physically also totally opposite and
they said like who and I said Danny
DeVito and they said that is a brilliant
idea I know Danny let me call him so I
haven't called him Danny loved the idea
we all sat down had lunch signed a
napkin Wow the movie Wow and then he
went to Tom Pollock and then he you know
put them to put together the details and
we went often how long does it take Ivan
to come back at you with the script
after you have this kind of
brainstorming session I got a story a
five page story already I would say two
months after we met in Aspen it's no
mess I mean you're laughing because he
goes listen some guy you know the
leftover shitty sperm is
Danny DeVito to me to me now I know now
I see the young writer but like it is
hilarious so that's but now we're
talking about a sequel where we have
actually been refined that the you know
out we find out that the funeral of our
mother that you know when we read the
will that there's three of us who's
gonna be the third Bradley Murphy how
did that happen it'd be of
african-american coming in here yeah if
the over said this our brother so now we
don't have to do the research but we can
only get the money if we find him how we
have to get them involved how far along
you and they have a script it has to be
like most scripts fine-tuned right and
so they're fine-tuning it right now and
you know but I mean he Murphy loves the
idea Danny DeVito and I we had lunch
with Eddie Murphy and or with my house
and we talked about the whole thing and
we were laughing and laughing the whole
the whole meal through because it was
such a funny idea and of course is who
wouldn't like it